hello everyone last weekend the chess
championship of my chess club began and
this is my game from round one of this
tournament we postponed the game because
my opponent couldn't make it on Saturday
so we agreed that we will play it today
on Monday and I just finished playing
this game got back from the Chess Club
and I thought I tried to you as its it's
quite interesting my opponent here as
some of you may remember him from my
stream is DOMA GUI for college also
lives in my hometown here and well you
might remember him a lot of you called
him a dodo the engine boy as he was he
wasn't talking too much on the stream as
he was only calculating lines so that's
him that's my opponent I think his
rating is around eighteen hundred and
fifty here you can see him this is a
full photo of him this is him and Gary
Kasparov the photo was taken last year
in December when Casper was held in
holding a simultaneous exhibition in
Zagreb so as you can see he is quite the
chess enthusiasts and he really enjoys
the game and every year we play in our
chess club championship when I get the
white pieces I play e4 he goes for the
French and when he gets the white pieces
he plays d4 and I always go either for
the Pannonia or something depending on
the mood so today I wanted to mix it up
I knew I had the black pieces and I
prepared for him the budapest gambit but
when the game started and we got at the
board he surprised me already on the
first move as he played before the
Polish opening and when I saw this I
immediately remembered that video I made
it was a Bobby Fischer game from Fischer
simultaneous exhibition and in that
video I told you that if anyone plays b4
against you go e 5 and after Bishop to
b2 simply grab that pawn and after he
captures it play Knight to f6 and this
is the advice I gave you in my video so
I felt kind of obligated to do this
myself so I did go for this
I played Knight to f6 here and he played
c3 now here I have the option of
retreating to e7 or playing Bishop to a5
Bishop to e7 I felt it was the stronger
move but I decided not to go
backwards I decided to play Bishop to a5
I don't really mind this I mean it's not
like this Bishop isn't g5 and I don't
want to like I said I don't want to go
backwards and here after white pushes d4
I felt that the bishop on a5 will be
very useful in fighting for the center
as it pins the c3 pawn so here he played
III preparing before and here I could
have castled but I decided to go d6
first making him choose what's he gonna
do with the Bishop Bishop to d4 doesn't
make any sense I simply push e 5 if he
goes Bishop to g3
that Bishop really I don't know that
doesn't really have a bright future as
my pawns are on c c7 and and d6 so here
he decided to capture it and this is the
best move
he played Bishop captures okay one other
thing it's important to see that Queen
to a4 isn't doing anything for white
although it does seem like the bishop
here is attacked but after Knight to c6
and the bishop captures Queen captures
Queen Bishop to b5 now threatening
Bishop captures on c6 with check and
winning the bishop but here Bishop to d7
and after Bishop captures Bishop
captures now if you capture the bishop
you get b6 and after the Queen moves now
Bishop captures on g2 and now white
loses a rook so after d6 dodo decided to
play Bishop captures on f6 this is the
best move Queen captures and not be for
here i castled Bishop to d3 by him c5 as
I thought I just placed c5 you know
going immediately for that a nice center
he created that c3 d4 III structure next
I thought I'd play Knight to c6 and
depending on what he does with the
knight and g1 I will only then decide
how to develop my light square bishop so
here he played Knight to e2 not allowing
Knight of three and then the pin with
the bishop on g4 so 92 fighting for the
center and also preparing Castle here I
played Knight to c6 and here he castled
now the C pawn isn't pinned anymore so
the C pawn can capture on d4 so there is
no threat on d4 I played Bishop to g4
now with the idea of capturing the night
I need to if if my bishop is attacked
and here probably is the first moment
that he went wrong here h3 is a better
move after h3 I have to capture and
after Queen Queen captures either g6 or
rook a to c8 and the game the game
continues it's a it's a pretty equal
position but here after Bishop to g4 he
decided to play f3 and at first I was I
was kind of annoyed by this move because
well I really liked my bishop on g4 and
I have to move it now where do I move it
and I thought okay f3 he will have
support for efore but I thought that f3
was weakening the King said a bit too
much and this will prove to be correct
I played Bishop to e6 and here he played
Knight to f4 one idea you have to see
that d5 doesn't really do anything for
white if d5 Bishop captures yes he does
have this Bishop captures on h7 but
after King captures and he grabs the
piece back white doesn't really gain
anything he only messed up his pawn
structure now he has this week c3 pawn
so it's a better position for black so
after this Bishop to e6 move he played
Knight to f4 and here is a very nice
moment in the game as I played d5 here
another option I had instead of playing
d5 was actually see captures on d4 and
the reason I didn't see this as because
after see captures on d4 and see capture
Sundy for I do have Knight captures on
d4 and now of course if I capture Sun d4
III recapture with the Queen this is
check and then I win the rook
but after Knight to a three it's not all
that clear I mean I did grab a pawn but
I can't I kind of missed that this
Knight can stay here as the pawn on e3
is also defending the knight on f4 so so
it's hard to say it seemed a bit
complicated from that nasty position in
the center
so after this Knight to f4 move I played
d5 and I actually felt that D Phi was a
really a really good move it's it's kind
of allowing me
some more activity with this Bishop I
can always after this night either
capture so I kick it away I can always
go Bishop to c7 some Queen to h6 ideas
threatening some moves on h2 as this f3
did weaken the Kings side so I did play
d5 and here he played Knight captures on
e6 Queen captures on e6 here and here
I'm attacking his III pawn and and as
you can see as he pushed f3 now this e
pawn does seem a bit weak and here
probably rook to e1 is the best idea but
after rook to e8 you can see that that
pawn is is really weak and that it's
gonna be a weakness for quite a while
I can't even push f5 and really make it
stay on e3 for the entire game but yeah
and even c3 is now a liability as the
bishop on a5 is also now I think that
rook anyone so after Queen captures on
e6 he decided to push efore and E 4 E 4
I immediately saw that if or losses upon
but I I just had to figure out a way how
to exactly capture it so I played seek
after Sun d5 seek after Sun d5 and now
Bishop to b6 as there is no way to
defend this pawn on d4 now I'm just
pinning it again and now I have all
sorts of threats he played he captures
on d5 Queen captures on d5 and here
Knight to a 3 and here is one-one really
nice moment in the game I saw that I
started after Bishop captures pawn with
check he will play King to h1 and then I
can't capture the rook because Bishop
captures on h7 and I lose the Queen on
d5 but actually I could have played
Bishop capture some before because after
Bishop captures on d4 this is check king
h1 now I have this Queen to c5 move the
bishop is still attacking the rook and
now my queen is attacking the knight on
a3 and after he defends it would cling
to c1 I simply captured the Queen rook
captures and now I have this Bishop to
b2 and this wins the exchange so I
unfortunately missed this
so after Knight to a3 I decided to go
with a different plan I decided to go
with wood
plan that involves a very nice checkmate
I played Queen captures on d4 with chick
he played king h1 and now I played rook
a to the 8th developing the piece and
now there's a double attack on his
Bishop on d3 and the bishop cannot be
defended so he has to move the bishop he
decided to play Bishop to e4 and now I
play Queen to e5 this opens up an attack
from my rook to his queen and b1 and
here he has to choose a place for the
Queen
he played Queen to c2 now attacking my
pawn on h7 and here I just played Knight
to d4 and here I saw that if he captures
that's that's not good for white if he
captures it then came to h8 and now his
queen is still attacked if you play
something like Queen to b4 I play simply
Queen to h5 and now he's losing
he's losing this bishop there is nowhere
for the bishop to go g6 is covered f5 is
covered by the Queen and the night and
if instead of Queen to e4 he plays
something like Queen to d3
again simply Queen to h5 and after he
retreats with Bishop to b4 now there's
this Knight to f5 move and this is
winning the game
he's either losing two knights the g3
checkmate or he's losing the Queen so
after this Knight d4 move
he played Queen to be one and here I
thought about a lot of things I I spent
a lot of time calculating some ideas
here like rook to d6 with some ideas of
sacrificing my queen on h2 and then
trying some rook to h6 ideas but I
always was a one tempo short if I could
only bring this Knight to e2 then this
would be a while but a viable idea but
if I play nice the rook to d6 he'll
immediately go Knight to c5 attacking my
queen my rock my bishop so I didn't have
time for this so I decided to go Queen
to h5 first getting my Queen out of that
e5 square so it's a adult arrange for
the night and here white doesn't really
have a lot of good moves well no moves
are really good for white he doesn't he
doesn't really have a chance to activate
its Knight anymore
as now Bishop to c7 is coming so here he
went into kind of a deep thing he I
think he spent them around 15 minutes
maybe 20 I really don't know
and he played Bishop characters on b7 as
if as if nothing was happening on the
board and here probably maybe he was
expecting rook to b8 I'm the bishop but
after the bishop retreats I really don't
have a good discovery with my dark
square bishop but he probably missed
this move as this is the move I played I
played Knight to e2 and now on
threatening Knights the g3 checkmate and
there was only one way to stop this and
that is actually Queen who you want this
is what he played and now I thought
about playing Bishop to c7 Bishop to c7
does does win the game but after Bishop
to c7 he has to push f4 to prevent
checkmate and now I simply capture it
still threatening checkmate and after
rook captures I have Knight captures I
wouldn't exchange and probably I mean
I'm winning this game but I saw that I
still have to play the game on this
could last for for a long time as he's a
persistent offender so instead after
this Queen to e1 move I didn't go for
the Bishop to c7 first I played rook F
to e e8 as I as much as I tried I
couldn't find a move for white that
works in this position because now
having that
rupini 8 the threat of Bishop to c7 is
is much more potent and here he really
again doesn't have a good move here he
thought that this wasn't really a good
idea
he played Bishop 3 4 now blocking my
rook but now now I played Bishop to c7
and now be sure to c7 is disastrous for
white as now he doesn't have the option
of pushing f4 anymore at the block
checkmate because if f4 I simply grabbed
a bishop so here he was forced to play
h3 here H 3 was played if if he plays g3
I simply capture it with with the knight
the pawn is pinned so he played h3 here
I played in Nigeria check King g1 and
here I can win a piece by Quincy 5 check
the king is in check and I window Knight
and
three but I also saw another idea how to
win the exchange and a piece so I
decided to go for that one
I played Knight captures on f1 and now
if he captures with the Queen
I still have Queen to c5 check winning
this night so he has to play King
characters on f1 and now I just pushed
f5 attacking this bishop and the bishop
is pinned of course he played Queen to
seize the Queen to c3 and now he is
threatening to capture my bishop as well
but now now it's game over
I seem to play F F captors on e4 he
captured my bishop and now comes he
captures on f3 if he captures I grab
both the Queen he's getting checkmated
if he pushes or something I simply grab
on h3 so here he played rope to be one F
captors and g2 this is with Czech Kings
you want Queen captures on h3
threatening Queen to h1 I've played
rugby 7 and here rob t1 and in this
position don't wait for college resigned
at the game as its mating one after King
to have to pawn comes to g1 promotes low
Queen and this is checkmate
so a very interesting game and I spent
like an hour yesterday preparing my
budapest gambit for him and he really he
really surprised me in the first
movement he went for the Polish opening
but as I didn't make that video for you
how to treat the beef the beef the
Polish opening I felt I felt like you
know if this was played in a Fischer
game then it it must be playable so yeah
one thing yeah one thing I missed it's
it's in this position after Bishop to c7
after he played h3 and I played Knight
the g3 check King G 1 and here after I
captured this rook
I was only considering this because I
saw it wins apiece either after I
capture it if the Queen captures then I
have Quincy v check winning the night or
if the King characters I push f5 as I
did in the game and I only considered
these two possibilities but there was an
even greater possibility but I
considered the move rook captures on e4
but I I don't know
I quickly gave up on the idea but what
captures on e4 is is a very deadly move
after rook captures on e4 white captures
of course with the pawn you can capture
with the Queen pawn captures and now
comes Knight to e2 check the idea is if
King to have to then Bishop to b6 is
checkmate this is very nice
and if King goes to h1 only other square
the King can go to as the bishop is
covering h2 then comes Queen to e5 and
now there is no defense against Queen -
H - checkmate you can block it with the
g3 but now Knight captures on g3 this is
with check King g1 and Knight captures
on e4 again threatening checkmate I have
to rook to f2 oMG 3 check rope blocks
and now comes Bishop to b6 check King to
h1 and out comes Queen captures on h3
checkmate Rock h2 again Queen to f3
checkmate rook g2 and now Rock to d2 and
it's game over but this is this is a lot
of moves and although I want the game
quick quicker than then it would take me
in this variation I just show you it's
it's a much nicer variation you know
it's a very nice forcing variation
capturing with the bishop on e4 and then
just forcing all the moves but yeah I
missed this because I was checking out
to other winning moves and not even
realizing that there was an even greater
winning move so and one interesting
thing about this game as I was playing
it I really felt that I was playing the
strongest moves of course deep down
inside I know that I'm actually not
playing the strongest moves because I
analyze Grandmaster games on a daily
basis and I see that they make a lot of
mistakes so of course I know I'm not
making the strongest moves but I really
really felt like there weren't any
better moves than the ones I was making
so this is a one example of why it's
extremely important to analyze your own
games because you will see just how many
things you miss and maybe second time
you will be in a situation like this you
will get an idea you will see a pattern
that was already in a position
missed because you analyzed it so there
are a lot of benefits obviously to
analyzing your own games especially the
ones you lost and the ones you drew and
I think it's Kasparov who said the most
important games to analyze are the ones
that you win because you probably missed
a lot of things in those games and if
you don't find it in your analysis your
opponent will and next time it will be
you who will be suffering so yeah that's
the game haven't shown my own game in a
while I think this is the first game
I've shown on my channel where I
actually won the game all the games so
far I've shown were either drawn or lost
so I do hope you enjoyed it and as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here I would like to thank a bay John
Bugatti and Tareq Marc for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it thank y'all
for watching and I will see you soon
probably with another classic